الامريكيه نشر الغواصه يو اس اس فلوريدا
التي تعمل بالطاقه النوويه في الشرق
الاوسط لتعزيز الامن والاستقرار البحري في
المنطقه وقد نقلت صحيفه
ردع حلفاء ايران عن مهاجمه مصالح واشنطن
وحلفائها بعد تلاقيها معلومات عن تخطيط
ايران لتنفيذ هجمات وشيكه في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي الرسائل التي
تبعثها الولايات المتحده بارسال قطعه
حربيه نوويه الى الشرق الاوسط في هذا
التوقيت وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان تستقبل وما
مدى اتساق هذه الخطوه مع مظله يتردد في
الفتره الماضيه عن تغيير واشنطن اولويات
حضورها العسكري من الشرق الاوسط الى الشرق
الاقصى ومنعكاسات هذا التحرك الامريكي على
امن المنطقه في ضوء ما نقل عن مسؤولين
امريكيين بشان استعداد ايران لتنفيذ هجمات
وشيكه في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
بحسب ما نقلته وكاله بلومبرج عن قياده
القوات المركزيه البحريه الامريكيه ومقرها
البحرين فاذا الغواصه النوويه الامريكيه
يو اس اس فلوريدا بدات الجمعه عبوره قناه
السويس قادمه من البحر الابيض المتوسط في
طريقها الى منطقه الشرق الاوسط وفي حين
رفض متحدث باسم البحريه تحديد ما اذا كانت
الغواصه متجهه الى الخليج فانه اكد ان
الهدف من نشرها تعزيز الامن والاستقرار
البحري في المنطقه من دون تفاصيل اضافيه
عن مهمتها يذكر ان الغواصه uss فلوريدا
التي تعمل بالطاقه النوويه واحده من اربع
غواصات فقط مزوده بصواريخ موجهه في اسطول
البحريه الامريكيه وهي غواصه هجوميه قادره
على حمل ما يصل الى
154 صاروخ كروز من طراز توماهوك
ما احشم عن الكشف عن تفاصيلها المتحدث
باسم البحريه الامريكيه كشفت جانبا منه
صحيفه
حين ذكرت نقلا عن مسؤولين امريكيين قولهم
ان ارسال الغواصه يو اس اس فلوريدا الى
الشرق الاوسط في هذا التوقيت نوع من
استعراض القوه ياتي على خلفيه معلومات
استخباراتيه تركتها لاداره الامريكيه
مفادها ان ايران تخطط لتنفيذ هجمات وشيكه
في المنطقه اضافت الصحيفه ان هذه الخطوه
جزء مما سمته تحركا اوسعا يقوم به
الفانتاجون لتعزيز قواته في المنطقه من
اجل ردع القوات المدعومه من ايران عن
مهاجمه مصالح الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من واشنطن
الدكتور تشارلز دان كبير والباحثين في
مركز دراسات الشرق الاوسط والدبلوماسيه
الامريكي السابق على ان ينضم الينا لاحقا
في سياق هذه الحلقه ضيف اخر من ايران اذا
دكتور تشارلز دان ما وظيفه هذه
الغواصه التي تعمل بطاقه النوويه والتي
يتم نشرها في المنطقه
ان نشر هذه الغواصه يبعث برسالتين
اساسيتين اولهما الى ايران في فتره تشهد
فيها المنطقه توترات وخوف من اعتداءات
ايرانيه سواء كانت بريه او بحريه وهذا مع
تزايدت المخاوف الامريكيه بشانه فهي
تؤشر بان الولايات المتحده قادره على
الدفاع المصالحه هناك ايضا رساله اخرى به
الاهميه نفسها وهي رساله موجهه الى
السعوديه والى دول اخرى من دول الخليج
العربي
مفادها ان الدبلوماسيه الصينيه مفيده جدا
فيما يتعلق بالحجم من التوترات
الاقليميه ولكن المشاكل الرئيسيه بين
ايران ودول الخليج العربي لم تحل لم تحل
اي منها والولايات المتحده تبقى الفاعل او
الطرف الخارجي الاقوى القادر على فرض
الامن في الخليج
هذا هي الرساله الرئيسيه الثانيه من عمليه
نشر الغواصه طيب عندما تقول ان الرساله
الاولى لايران مفادها ان الولايات المتحده
قادره على الدفاع عن مصالحها ماذا يعني
ذلك قادر على الدفاع عن مصالحها بوجه من
وممن
انها رساله موجهه مباشره الى طهران
مؤخرا كان هناك اعتداء من خلال الصواريخ
من قبل قوات الايرانيه ضد احد المرافق
الامريكيه في سوريا
وتوفي امريكي وردت الولايات المتحده وهذا
النوع من الوضع او من الاوضاع يمكنه ان
يتصاعد سريعا وتبعث الولايات المتحده
بانذار مفاده ان لا تريد تصعيد هذا الوضع
والا سوف ترد بقوه كبيره كذلك تعتبر
الولايات المتحده ان هناك اعتداءات محتمله
اضافيه من قبل ايران اعتداءات بحريه بدون
ان يكون هناك مؤشرات فعاليه تعمل كشف عنها
لكن الولايات المتحده تحذر من انه اذا
حصلت اعتداءات فهي قادره تماما على مساله
ايران المحاسباتها على تصرفاتها ضد اي
شاحن امريكيه او غيرها انوه بانها ليست
المره الاولى التي تبعث بها الولايات
المتحده الى او بغواصه الى المنطقه فهذا
يحصل سنويا على الاقل منذ 2020 احيانا
موقع الغواصه يتم الاعلان عنه كما حصل
الان وفي احيانا اخرى لا يعلن عنه ولكن
هذا ليس بامر غريب بالنسبه لما تقوم به
الولايات المتحده وفي كل مره هي تشير الى
زياده التوتر مع ايران وهذا هو السياق ما
يحصل حاليا لكن هل
ترى السيد دكتور تشارلز دان ان هذا
التحذير سيكون مفيدا بمعنى انه سيكون
راضعا ام انه يؤدي ربما وظيفه عكسيه ويزيد
من التوترات في المنطقه لا سيما مع ايران
هنا اتحدث عن ايران تحديدا لان سناتي على
الموضوع السعودي بعد قليل
[موسيقى]
يبدو انه حين نشرت هذه الغواصات من قبل لم
يستتبع ذلك ارتفاع كبير في التوترات او
حتى مواجهات مسلحه بين الولايات المتحده
وطاهران ما تريد الولايات المتحده ان تقوم
به وان تبعث برساله مافادها اننا نحاول ان
نضبط الوضع ونمنعه من التصعيد ونحن
مستعدون ولكن بالنظر الى التوترات
الاقليميه واحد الامثله على ذلك قد ذكرته
ولكن ايضا ما يحصل في اسرائيل وفلسطين
وتبادل الصواريخ بين اسرائيل وحماس في غزه
ولبنان طبعا هناك هذا الاحتمال ان الوضع
قد يخرج عن السيطره في اي لحظه وهذا ما
يقلق الولايات المتحده لا يمكنني ان اقول
اذا كان هدف فعلا سوف يرضع طهران ام لا او
اذا كان سوف يهدئ الوضع ولكن هذا ما تامله
الولايات المتحده بكل تاكيد ذكرت ان
الرساله الثانيه من و راء نشر هذه الغواصه
هي موجهه للسعوديه ومفادها كما قلت ان
الدبلوماسيه الصينيه مفيده ولكنها لا تحل
المشاكل في المنطقه ماذا يعني ذلك عن وجهه
النظر الامريكيه مما يحصل لاسيما
في ظل هذا التقارب الجاري بين السعوديه
وايران بدفع او ببساطه صينيه
نريد ان الكثير ممنوع ممن يراقبون الوضع
يقولون ان الولايات المتحده
من تدخل الصين في هذه الجهود الدبلوماسيه
ونجاحها الكبير فيها انا لا اعتقد ان هذا
هو رد الفعل الحقيقي في واشنطن فرد الفعل
الحقيقي هو نعم هذا جيد نريد ان نهدئ من
التوترات في المنطقه في المسار الصحيح
ولكن الولايات المتحده من خلال نشر
الغواصه
ومبادره اخرى على غرار الاستعداد لتعزيز
الاسلحه على المنطقه والنظر في ضمانات
امنيه اضافيه في المنطقه تقول مره اخرى ان
امناكم يعتمدوا بطريقه كبيره على التعاون
مع الولايات المتحده وعلى الابقاء على
علاقات جيده معها
اعتقد ان النشا الغوا طبعا رمزي في هذا
السياق
ويعكس الرايه الامريكي
وتريد واشنطن ان تقول ان الصين لا يمكنها
ولا ترغب حتى في ان تستبدل الولايات
المتحده في هذه الفتره الزمنيه طيب
ابقى معي دكتور تشارلزال انضم الينا الان
من طهران الدكتور عماد ابشيناز رئيس نقابه
مراكز الابحاث والدراسات في ايران سيد
دكتور عماد
ابشناز اذا البحريه الامريكيه تعلن عن
وصول هذه الغواصه التي تعمل بالطاقه
النوويه وهي مزوده بالصواريخ الى المنطقه
ووفق البيان تقول ان هدفها هو نشر الامن
والاستقرار البحري الاقليمي كيف رات
ايران هذه الخطوه
تحياتي لك للضيف العزيز والمشاهدين الكرام
بالتاكيد يعني الولايات المتحده منزعجه
بشكل كبير من التقارب الايراني السعودي
مثلها مثل الكيان الصهيوني يعني راينا
خلال
اسبوعين الماضيين ان الكيان الصهيوني قام
يعني زياده التوتر في المنطقه تاره بدا
بقصف
يومي للمواقع في سوريا وتاره اخرى اعتدى
على المصلين في المسجد الاقصى وتحرش
بالفلسطينيين لكي يعني يقوم بتفجير الوضع
الامني في هذه المنطقه يعني اذا كانت
الولايات المتحده مهتمه
بثبات هذه المنطقه وامن هذه المنطقه لربما
عليها ان ترضع الكيان الصهيوني
وايران وباقي الدول المنطقه ليس لديهم اي
مشكله اليوم مشكله امنيه او عسكريه تحتاج
الحضور الامريكي في هذه المنطقه
عمليا الولايات المتحده تريد ان تقول هذه
المنطقه
لربما هي
حديقه الخلفيه للصينيين للايرانيين ولن
اسمح لكم بان تهدئوا الاوضاع في هذه
المنطقه دون وجودي يعني عمليا الاتفاق
الايراني السعودي حصل بمباركه
يعني بدعم صيني دون علم الولايات المتحده
دون حضور الولايات المتحده دون التنسيق مع
الولايات المتحده بالتاكيد الولايات
المتحده غاضبه الولايات المتحده لم تستطع
منذ تاسيسها ولحد اليوم لم تستطع حل اي
مشكله في العالم عبر الدبلوماسيه كل مكان
دخلت فيه الولايات المتحده دخلت معه
الويلات والحروب والدمار وغيره يعني انا
سمعت العزيز يتكلم عن بيع الاسلحه للمنطقه
وغيرها هذا لن يعني لن يؤدي الى تخفيض
التوتر يعني هذه الامور لا تؤدي
الدبلوماسيه تؤدي الى تخفيض التواتر ذكرت
ان نشر هذه الغواصه ياتي على خلفيه
معلومات استخباريه لدى الجانب الامريكي
بان ايران تخطط لتنفيذ هجمات وشيكه في
المنطقه وهي بالتالي تاتي الى المنطقه
يعني الحفاظ على الاستقرار هنا ولمنع مثل
هكذا هجمات كيف ترد على هذه النقطه
يعني كل ما تريد الولايات المتحده ان تهدد
الدول العربيه خاصه السعوديه تقوم بنشر
تسريب هكذا معلومات عبر وسائل الاعلامها
ليس هناك اي تهديد من قبل ايران لاي دوله
جاره خاصه السعوديه التي اليوم نحن يعني
في نسير في طريق
المصالحه معها وباقي دول المنطقه يعني ليس
فقط السعوديه ليس هناك اي تهديد من قبل
ايران والجميع يعلمون ذلك يعني الدول
العربيه وايران جميعا يعني متفقين على حل
مشاكلهم
والتخلص من الفتنه الامريكيه الصهيونيه في
هذه المنطقه الولايات المتحده يعني كل مره
يكون هناك حديث عنا المصالحه تاتينا بهكذا
اخبار كاذبه تنشر هذه الاخبار الكاذبه
في هذه المنطقه
اذا وجهه نظر ضيفنا من ايران هي ان
المنطقه عمليا ذاهبه نحو تفاهمات ذاهبه
نحو تهدئه بفضل هذا التقارب الايراني
السعودي والولايات المتحده اتيا لتنسف ذلك
ما رايك
رايي وانا ايران لديها سجل حافل
بالاعتداءات على
جيرانها وجودها في العراق في سوريا دعما
للديكتاتور
بشار الاسد بالاضافه الى الاعتداء على
بواخر الشحن بما فيه ما يتعلق
بالمناوشات مع البحريه الامريكيه في
المنطقه والحوثيون في اليمن كل ذلك لم يحل
سوف نرى اذا كان هذا التقارب بين ايران
والسعوديه سوف يؤدي فعلا يعتهدئه توترات
او الحد من الاعتداءات الايرانيه في
المنطقه وانه فقط مجرد اعاده فتح قنوات
دبلوماسيه مثل السفارات او تفتح السفارات
بدون تقارب فعلي الشيطان يكمن في تفاصيل
وسنرى قريبا ما هي هذه التفاصيل لكن ما
المشكله يعني لماذا لا يعطى هذا التقارب
فرصه خصوصا ان الجميع يبدو ملت زما به حتى
الان لماذا تريد الولايات المتحده ان
تتدخل بما يمنع ربما هذا التقارب او كما
ذكرت لك ينسفه كما
عبر عن ذلك ضيفنا من ايران
اولا انا لا اقبل القول ان الولايات
المتحده غاضبه او مستاءه او تريد تقويض
ذلك نصف ذلك دعونا لا ننسى ان اداره بايدن
قالت ان احد اساس سياستها في المنطقه هو
دبلوماسيه الاقليميه وحمل الدول في هذه
المنطقه الى حل مشاكلها بنفسها وما حصل
بين ايرين والسعوديه خطوه في المسار
الصحيح ولا اعتقد ان الاداره الامريكيه
فعلا غاضبه ومستائه لان الصين قد ساعدت في
اعاده فتح السفارتين بين دولتين السفارتان
كانتان موجودتين حتى 2016 وبالتالي هناك
انقطاع
عمره بضع سنوات لا بالعلكسي من ذلك درجات
المتحده في ذلك امرا جيدا ولكنها تريد
حلولا ديبلوماسيه لمشاكل فعليه ولكنها لا
تزال ترى التهديد موجوده من قبل ايران
لاسيون بالنظر الى تصرفاتي الحكومه
الايرانيه التي اتيت على ذكرها ولهذا
السبب
تراقب الولايات المتحده عن كثب موضوع
الامن الخليجي وهذا هي الرساله الرئيسيه
لنشر غواصه يا اس اس فلويد الا تعتقد
دكتور عماد ابشناز انا لهذه الرساله صدى
ربما في الخليج تحديدا عندما يقول الدكتور
تشارلز دان ان الرساله الامريكيه مفردها
ان امن دول الخليج يعتمد على التعاون مع
الولايات المتحده الا ترى ان
في ذلك يعني
واقعيه الى حد بعيد
لا في هذه هذا الموضوع ليس هناك واقعيه
هو يعني عمليا تصرف او غطرسه امريكيه
لربما السيد تشارلز لا يعرف عن التفاصيل
ولكن انا اعلم على العديد من التفاصيل في
المفاوضات التي حصلت احد اهم هذه التفاصيل
هي ان دول المنطقه تريد تامين امنها
بنفسها هي لا تريد الولايات المتحده التي
قامت باحتلال العراق اليوم وقامت اليوم
تحتل قسم من سوريا واليوم موجوده بقوتها
في هذه المنطقه بعيده عشره الاف كيلو متر
عن اراضيها وتقوم بتنفيذ
الاجندات وفقا لمصالحها ليس وفقا لمصالح
دول المنطقه يعني انتبهي جيدا على كلام
الدبلوماسيين والمسؤولين الامريكيين هم لا
نحن هنا لحمايه مصالح دول المنطقه او او
حلفائنا يقولون نحن هنا لحمايه المصالح
الامريكيه دول المنطقه تريد ان تحمي
مصالحها وحمايه مصالح دول منطقه تقتضي
بالتعاون الاقليمي الولايات المتحده
مستاءه من التعاون الاقليمي بين دول
المنطقه والذي هو ضمن تفاصيل الانتفاع
الامثله سواء في اليمن في سوريا
للعوامل عدم الاستقرار التي ربما تساهم
بها ايران ذكر لك العديد من الامثله وقال
ان هذا كلها غير محلوله
تفضل ابدا كل هذه تسببت بها الولايات
المتحده الولايات المتحده احتلت العراق
الولايات المتحده دمرت العراق الولايات
المتحده دمرت الجيش العراقي لحد الان
اموال العراق موجوده في الولايات المتحده
ولا يسمحون للحكومه العراقيه بالاستفاده
من اول لفتها هم يسرقون العراق ويذهبون
الى حد هذه اللحظه كيف تسمى بمن حصل في
اليمن
دكتور عماد
الولايات المتحده لو لم تحتل العراق لو لم
تصنع داعش لما حصلت مشكله في سوريا ايران
موجوده في سوريا بطلب من قبل الحكومه
الشرعيه
السوريه والمعترف بها دوليا بالنسبه لليمن
الولايات المتحده شجعت على الحرب في اليمن
الولايات المتحده دفعت السعوديه الى
الدخول في هذا الحرب واقنعت السعوديه انها
سوف تنهي هذا الحرف في هذه المعركه في
اسبوعين وهذا لم يحصل لانها كانت تريد ان
تبيع السعوديه الاسلحه
يعني تسرق الاموال السعوديه الموجوده في
البنوك الامريكيه الان كان هناك حديث في
المرحله الماضيه عن ان الاولويات العسكريه
في الولايات المتحده
اختلفت وتذهب اكثر باتجاه الشرق الاقصى
واسيا هل بقدوم هذه الغواصه يعني ان هناك
اعاده خلط للاوراق وربما اعاده تركيز مره
اخرى من جانب الولايات المتحده على
المنطقه وعلى الشرق الاوسط
الولايات المتحده كانت تحاول ان تركز
بطريقه استراتيجيه اكبر على منطقه الهند
واسيا في السنوات الاخيره مع تركيز على
المسائل او اقل على المسائل الامنيه في
الشرق الاوسط ولكن الان تغير الوضع
للاسباب التي ذكرتها برايي الولايات
المتحده تشارك اكثر فاكثر استراتيجيا في
المنطقه
يلتقي الرئيس بايدن مع دول مجلس التعاون
بالاضافه الى دول الثلاثه وفي شهر يوليو
الماضي تعهد بان الولايات المتحده ستبقى
شاركا امنيا استراتيجيا للمنطقه اضيفوا
هنا اذا ارادت دول في المنطقه التي تدخل
الولايات المتحده في حل مشاكلها هذا لا
يفسر لي لماذا طلبت السعوديه ضمانات امنيه
من الولايات المتحده كما
افادل ويبدو لي ان دول
الخليجه تزال ترى
دعم الولايات المتحده كجزء
من العلاقات التي تتيح لها ان ترسم
سياستها الخارجيه بطريقه مستقله لانها
تعرف ان الولايات المتحده تدعمها اذا
هددتها ايران وقد هددتها في سنوات الاخيره
شكرا لك من واشنطن
شكرا لك
الباحثين في مركز دراسات الشرق الاوسط
والدبلوماسي الامريكي السابق وشكرا
للدكتور عماد رئيس نقابه مراكز الابحاث
والدراسات في ايران ضيفنا من طهران
الى هنا مشاهدينا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا لمتابعتكم الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]